all right hello everyone take your seats
please
thank you for taking the time out of
your busy schedules and joining us here
today here at the Dartmouth open campus
coalition we believe that free speech
and viewpoint diversity are fundamental
to our success not only as citizens but
as future leaders it is with my special
excitement that I'm pleased to announce
the Iran Institute's panel on free
speech on our campus we'd like to thank
the Iran Institute for bringing these
three incredible people to Dartmouth
without them this event wouldn't be
possible we appreciate the work of
Dartmouth's classroom technology
services and media production services
for helping make this event viewable to
a worldwide audience we'd also like to
thank conferences and events especially
Jim Albertini nyla Waddell and Donahoe
for their time and effort in helping
coordinate and plan logistics these
three were invaluable to the success of
the event lastly and most importantly we
would not be here today if Rachna Shah
did not work as tirelessly as she has to
build the docc and to initiate events
like this one thank you so much Rachna
today we have three outstanding people
joining us to start a conversation on
some very important issues facing
society especially on college campuses
unkar gotta is a senior fellow and chief
content officer at the ein Rand
Institute
he's the Institute's resident expert on
objectivism and serves as its senior
trainer and editor he has taught
philosophy for over ten years at the
Institute's objective academic center
dr. Gupta is a contributing author to a
number of books on rants fiction and
philosophy including essays on iron
Rand's The Fountainhead essays on Iran's
Atlas Shrugged why businessmen need
philosophy the capitalists guide to the
ideas behind iron Rand's Atlas Shrugged
concepts and the rollin knowledge
reflections on Objectivist epistemology
and a companion to eine rant yes me
Mohammad is an Arab Canadian college
instructor activist podcaster and author
who has written a memoir entitled from
al-qaeda to atheism in it she describes
how even though she was born and raised
in North America she endured the same
traumas that are familiar to Muslims
across the planet as a child she was
beaten for not memorizing the Quran as a
teenager she was forced into a marriage
to a member of al Qaeda after he was
bailed out of prison by Osama bin Laden
and as an adult she wore niqab and lived
in a home slash prison with paper
covering all the walls
windows yes mean is a member of the
prestigious Center for inquiry speakers
bureau she's also on the board of
advisors for the brighter brains
Institute an organization that builds
secular schools as well she is a coast
on the popular secular jihadist podcast
Dave Rubin is a talk show host comedian
and TV personality the host of the
popular YouTube talk show the Rubin
report Dave regularly addresses big
ideas such as free speech political
correctness and religion among many
other high-profile guests on his show
dave has interviewed sam harris ayaan
Hirsi Ali and Larry elder the I Rand
Institute fosters a growing awareness
understanding and acceptance of an
Rand's philosophy objectivism in order
to create a culture whose guiding
principles are reason rational
self-interest individualism and
laissez-faire capitalism student
programs are a major focus of the
Institute and include annual essay
contests that award nearly a hundred
thousand in prizes student conferences
student clubs support seasonal
internships and campus events like this
one visit Iran dot org to learn more
conflicts over free speech are becoming
more and more common this year has seen
riots at UC Berkeley an attack on
speakers at Middlebury College
protesters blocking a talk at Claremont
McKenna College students taking over
Evergreen State College approach and
protest of professor Jordan Peterson
over his refusal to use gender-neutral
pronouns off campus we have seen violent
clashes at political gatherings and
protests by white supremacists over the
removal of Confederate statues what is
the cause of these incidents what can we
do to address them and to protect
freedom of speech and the free society
that depends on it our panel is going to
be discussing these questions for us
today and many more so without further
ado please join me in welcoming Onkar
got a yes mean Mohamed and Dave Reuben
[Applause]
all right thank you guys we are live
streaming on my channel right now so
first off can you make some noise for
the people that are watching this at
home with a porn tab open right next to
them can you make some noise I always I
always just assume people are watching
my show and if it ever gets boring they
just click over to pornhub I don't
that's just my thoughts on it all right
we are we are very excited to to be here
I was at Berkeley two days ago and I
survived that so if I survive Berkeley I
sense I can probably survive Dartmouth
you guys you guys look nice this is like
a good everyone smiling look at you all
very respectable and smiley you're all
well-dressed alright I think we're gonna
have fun here you know it's funny I I
flew in from from LA last night and I
flew to the Boston Logan Airport and I
was supposed to take one of these tiny
little Cessna like four-person planes
and I was not happy but I was gonna do
it Yasmine actually did do it she's
still in a state of shock as you can see
but my flight got delayed so I ended up
taking a car and I took an uber for it's
about a two-hour drive to get here and
right when we passed into New Hampshire
there's the sign live free or die and I
lived in LA where the California state
motto is pay taxes and be quiet
so I'm excited to be here live free or
die we were all talking about what a
great phrase that is what what a great
place this is and you guys are out of
grade school so all right we're gonna
talk about free speech we're going to
sort of share your guys stories a little
bit we're gonna do about an hour of that
and then we're gonna do about an hour of
Q&A with you guys I thought first just
for for people you've been on my show
we've been trying to get you on card but
your agent is very difficult to work so
for people that don't know each of you I
thought maybe we could just do a quick
little little bio each and yeah I'll let
you go first
okay well Jacob did a good job of giving
a bit of background so born and raised
in Canada but in a very conservative
fundamentalist Orthodox Islamic home so
kind of
in a bubble living in Canada but not
really you know in my own home life was
was very conservative and I went to
Islamic schools and and like Jacob
mentioned I war ended up getting pushed
into a marriage with a man who I
discovered was a member of al-qaeda and
when I was married to him I was wearing
the club which is the full black
everything gloves and socks and and had
a daughter with him and then eventually
got away and went to university and when
I was there I just took a course called
history of religions because it was
gonna be focusing on the three Abrahamic
monotheistic religions and I thought
well I'll have one-third of that content
down for sure so I just took it to be
like an easy course not knowing that it
was gonna completely change the
trajectory of my life when I took that
course is when I discovered that a lot
of what I had been told about the Quran
being completely different from all
other religions and it's so divine and
it's the literal word of God and there's
nothing like it on this planet I
discovered that actually it was just
plagiarized a lot of the stories come
from Judaism and Christianity and and
pagan stories before that and so it just
took away all the divinity and that led
me down my path to the heathen that I am
today the non-believer and and yeah so
then I started writing a memoir after
the famous Sam Harris and Ben Affleck
clash on the Bill Maher show I started
to write a memoir and then I had people
contacting me from all over the Islamic
world telling me how much they related
to my story and so then I kind of fell
into speaking out more mostly because
people in those countries cannot speak
out and so I felt compelled to
considering I'm in a free country that I
should
you know I should at least do that
that's that's why I'm here today yeah
well I'm glad you're here and it's nice
that you're not in the McCobb and I see
your beautiful hair
unkar so I'm a philosopher so I'm gonna
just give you my background sort of as
it relates to free speech and why I'm
very interested and passionate about the
issue and it I was a graduate student
during the Salman Rushdie affair when
there was a fatwa put on his head
and that and the West's response to that
fatwa was incredibly pathetic and it
really showcase for me that very few
people understand what free speech is
and are willing to defend it and that is
when I started getting really interested
in the issue of free speech because I
thought it's very precarious in the West
now and then 9/11 I was already working
at the Iran Institute and that and again
I mean obviously it was a momentous
event but the response to it and the
inability to even think that it might
have something to do with Islam and that
we're facing a movement that I would
term Islamic totalitarianism the
whitewashing of that and the inability
for people to speak on this that they
were shouted down and we were at the
Institute shouted that when it did a lot
of events and so on after 9/11 it that
further conquer ties for me that this is
the issue for the new millennia that if
free speech goes were finished and the
Danish cartoons which came a time in
five years after 9/11 and still people
can't face the issue and you've got
newspaper or editors and so in hiding in
fear for their lives and nobody in the
West no government really will stand up
and defend them and again the Institute
did a lot around that so this is an
ongoing issue and maybe we'll talk about
some of these events in more detail that
it's this is a right that the West
thought tremendous amount to secure the
right to freedom of speech and it's in
jeopardy it's in jeopardy
today and it's if that goes if you can't
speak you can't change the culture for
the better yeah and you know for the
record we've been talking about this
stuff over dinner and throughout the day
and we have some differences and we're
gonna get into our differences of
opinion and hopefully when when we do
the Q&A you guys a little challenge us
on on some of the differences that you
might have with us but but the free
speech on college campus since we're on
a college campus I thought that would be
the right way to start I I view this
basically as the single most important
issue of the day I mean I've been
bouncing around college campuses now for
the last year and the I think the number
one question that I get from you guys is
that you are afraid often to speak not
only within your peer group because you
don't want people to call you a bigot or
a racist because you may believe in
small government or low taxes or
something like that
but that with your own professors you're
afraid to challenge them because of what
the blowback might be to any of you just
quickly by show of hands or applause
Danny of you have that fear here I'm
wondering how much yes that's wow that's
about half of you right there so that's
that's kind of interesting to me that
that on college campuses I mean this is
the place this is the place where not
only are you supposed to learn history
you're supposed to learn how to think
and how to critically think and all that
but you're also is supposed to be
challenged and you're supposed to
challenge people too and I find it so
amazing consistently that so many
professors these days apparently seem to
be afraid to be challenged when that's
exactly what they should be trying to do
with you guys you are a teacher what do
you make of this phenomena I think it's
really sad it's like you said as as a
college instructor it's not teach it's
not telling students what to think it's
it's it's teaching them how to think you
know and there's this big controversy
about safe spaces these days and things
that you shouldn't talk about because
you're gonna trigger students and I
think that the entire university campus
is a place you know it shouldn't be a
safe space you know this is the place to
criticize and to argue
to question and that's the only way that
we can learn it's the only way we can
expand our minds I mean I grew up being
told that questioning something is the
devil whispering in my ear that if I
don't just do what I'm told and and
accept what I'm being taught then that's
evil right and so when I what's
happening these days is is really well
it's triggering to me so one of the
things we talked about this afternoon
was that you are shocked at someone that
has lived through what what
totalitarianism and what
authoritarianism actually does what you
lived through it and what clothes you
could wear and what thoughts you could
have in what in what people you could be
friends with etcetera etcetera
you're sort of I don't want to say
depressed but you you find the fact that
so many of these people on college
campus are so against so many of these
freedoms now you find it shocking is
that is that even the right adjective
yeah yeah it's it's yeah it is it's
depressing because I feel like what is
the end goal like what are you what are
you aiming for when you hear people
talking about shutting down speech and
burning books it's like what what are
you looking for you're looking for
Sharia law like what is where is this
going to lead but I don't think that
they think that far ahead they're just
you know I don't know I don't so it
seems to me that I try not to impugn
people's motives it's one of the things
I talk about on the show a lot I don't
want I don't believe that all the people
of the left are evil I think that the
ideology is bad leaders often are bad or
corrupt or have ideas that I think are
wrong but I don't think that the average
person or the average student that's on
a college campus that has those ideas is
evil what's the best way do you think to
counter some of those ideas or wake up
people who may not be evil but are just
mistaken
yeah I mean I think a lot of it is it's
a product of the education that you're
receiving and it's very one-sided and
particularly in the human
so all the sciences history economics
that deal with man if you look at the
history of the 20th century the it's
dominated by Marxist socialists and I
mean now what is the progressives that
was in the late 19th early 20th century
and it's one line of thought it does not
anywhere come close to all the views you
should be thinking about entertaining
discussing arguing about I mean part of
the reason I went into philosophy I was
already interested in Iran didn't
objectivism but the idea that that's all
I would read and that's all I would hear
I went to a university where it had a
lot of different viewpoints in
philosophy and I want to hear all the
theories all the viewpoints and there's
very little of that now that happens in
colleges and it's it's a crime against
you guys it's a crime against students
to do this distance I would never just
teach objectivism even though I think
it's right to students and no don't hear
about Plato don't you know about mark
I mean we read Marx in my classes I
don't think he's right about anything
basically but you have to know some of
the arguments and if you're gonna have a
view of your own you have to be over the
counter to the other arguments and if
you never hear them and if it's somehow
taboo and you're gonna shout them down
as they're racists or bigots just
because they disagree there's something
really has gone wrong with education and
it's that's what I think has to be
turned and it has to come in part from
the students damat like we want
something better than what we're getting
in the classroom yeah it's also
interesting to me how so many words have
flipped meaning I mean if I was to look
at you guys and I can see people that
are white and I can see people that are
brown and I can see girls and guys and
people of different ages and all that
and if we were to look at you only based
in those ideas that actually as I always
say this is prejudice that is prejudging
I don't expect because I look at you
that I know what any of your political
thoughts are or ideas are and yet we're
sold this idea of diversity constantly
as if this is how we should be looking
at each other that oh here we have black
people here they should think of
certainly Muslim people should think a
certain way white people should think a
certain way whatever it is this
actually it's the antithesis of the
American project it's completely the
reverse of Martin Luther King Junior's
most famous phrase about his children
being judged by the content of their
character not the color of their skin
and yet somehow this is like actually
caught fire with a certain set of people
yeah identity politics as is racism
basically it's the racism yeah it's
unfortunate and it's really insulting to
because people the ayaan Hirsi Ali when
she did her interview with you actually
was talking about how people look at her
and she's a black woman immigrant and
the progressives will look at her and
assume right away that she's a victim
and that she's being oppressed by this
horrible American society etc etc and of
course she is not she is an amazing
woman she's a survivor you know she's
she doesn't want those kinds of she
doesn't want anybody's pity mm-hmm
so she gets to define who she is other
people don't get to define it for her
but people are just looking at diversity
of identity versus diversity of opinion
or diversity of thought how do you think
victimhood got so sexy to people the
idea that victimhood is virtue or the
idea that because you were born a
certain color or a certain sexuality or
whatever that's outside of the
mainstream that somehow that gives you
extra Authority I mean I think that's a
philosophical viewpoint and it a lot of
it comes from religion that religion
plays up victimhood and if you just
think in Christianity think of Jesus in
the Sermon in the Mount
it's the meek and the poor and not on
the poor materially the poor in spirit I
mean we would have called it now now
losers that's who's gonna inherit the
earth
it's and that sets it up that the if you
don't have something if you don't have
intelligence if you don't have wealth if
you don't have a real soul you're poor
in spirit that's what gives you claims
to things all claims against whom the
people who've made something of their
spirit who the people who are strong in
various kinds of way intelligence and so
on and there's a real pact
Kachina the victimhood is you can think
of victims in two kinds of ways you're a
victim of injustice or you're a victim
just because you are a need or you're
suffering and so on and those are two
very different things and religion
package those together so there's a
tendency to think of someone's a victim
they must have suffered an injustice
that's not true
you can be a loser yeah and you deserve
to be at the bottom because you are
you're not a nice person you're not
honest you're not just and so you're at
the bottom it should be at the bottom
you're a criminal and you're in prison
and that's not the key but to elevate
that the mere fact that you're losing as
that is indicates something is wrong
that's not true but religion really
pushed that idea and then it became
secularized
and I mean Marxism is from each
according to his need from their
people's ability that's it elevated need
and the victim in to that's what counts
and it trumps everything so it's
interesting to me because the more that
I've had these conversations in the more
that I bring people on my show that that
are experts in this and they spend their
lives trying to dissect what's going on
here to me it just comes down to
absolute lazy thinking you don't have to
think if at the end of the day you view
it not only your victimhood as virtue
but you view the whole system against
you or that everyone else is has been
entitled to something and you have it
it's actually it's actually pretty
depressing
it's just negativity oh it's just a
circular negativity there's no where
there's nothing there's nothing positive
there's no where to go from there like
and then what okay so you're oppressed
the whole world is against you it's all
because of your skin color there's you
know there's nothing you can do about it
you're just everybody around you is
gonna be inherently racist and then what
can you briefly tell people what when
you finally woke up and you mentioned
your wake up moment before but just like
what did it take in you because I think
a lot of people have that I know I'm
sure there's people here who are sort of
quiet about what their private beliefs
are but wish they had a little more of
that that bravery or that mojo or moxie
to get out there and say what they think
well for me it was you know I'm speaking
to people who like in Pakistan or
right now the government is shutting the
other finding people on social media
that are speaking out against the
religion and they're abducting them
basically you know and some of them are
getting imprisoned they're being
tortured in prison and then they're
being let go again so that they can tell
their other liberal friends what happens
if you speak up you know in Bangladesh
there are bloggers you know that are
hacked to death in the street right Badu
II in Saudi Arabia has been doing 10
years again for just blogging about
humanism so when I'm speaking to people
that are in those kinds of situations
how can I not speak out you know it's of
course it's dangerous it's of course
it's uncomfortable I've been called a
Nazi sympathizer
I've been called an islamaphobe I've
been caught every racist I mean it the
things that don't even make any sense
yeah I get called at some point do they
just become meaningless
oh they yeah like being called a Nazi
sympathizer I was like okay yeah good
luck yeah you know but they just it's
the same they have their standard things
that they throw out right Oh bigoted
islamaphobe racist and it used to have
but this is part of when I was anonymous
before I had my face in my name out
there I used to get that stuff a lot
more yeah and if I they be like shut up
you're just a white woman what do you
know and I'd be like actually I'm Arab
you don't know anything about Islam
actually I was Muslim for a large part
of my life and so you know this part of
the reason why coming out and my having
my face out there and hazard Mohammed so
it's obvious that I come from a Islamic
background has has tempered a lot of
that criticism but they'll just go to
other things right but I feel like as as
much as as annoying as that is to deal
with with people just throwing it
obscenities at me it's not the same as
being imprisoned or you know being
lashed in the streets like what happens
in Saudi Arabia so you know I just read
this article yesterday
where they're saying that atheists are
whatever liberal free thinkers in those
countries cannot speak out so we in the
West have a duty to speak out and I
think that's what America is America is
all about that right you know be true to
your to who you are say the truth live
free or die you know like that's that's
true enlightenment values and that's
what for some reason I don't everybody
has gone soft I don't know yeah so I
mean this is one of the major things for
those of you who watch my show I mean
you know I talk about this all the time
that what has the left done to its
diverse thinkers what has it done to the
people who are actually liberal who care
about the individual who want to live
and let live I mean they're really
they've basically purged all of these
people and it's sort of becoming a
smaller and smaller I would argue more
radical group because if you just keep
purging everyone who thinks differently
be it half of the people that I've had
on my show from from someone like you or
Brett Weinstein the professor up at
Evergreen State in Washington or Lindsey
Shepherd from wilfred laurier or plenty
of other people that just say one little
thing that's a little different and
that's why it's so interesting to me
people will say to me well Dave you
don't give the right enough [ __ ]
basically and I always say well there's
actually a lot more diversity of thought
there I I go to events and I talk about
why I'm pro-choice and and I'm married
and I'm against the death penalty and
I'm for some level of public education
and the list goes on and on and I they
applaud me for it do you think that's
kind of new on the right but they're
sort of now being viewed as perhaps the
more tolerant side and the side more
interested in ideas I think that's a
particularly in America that's been a
big shift if and even so when I was
still undergrad in the 80 late 80s it's
I would think of it's still the left
even though I would disagree with them
and my professors and so on they're much
more intellectual than anyone I hear who
would be labeled on the right or as
conservatives and now fast forward 25
years or whatever it's not like that
anymore
it's you're much more interesting like
just interesting as a thinker that you
can see there's an intellect there to
listen to
and Shapiro then to listen to an average
college professor in in history or race
studies or I mean there's all kinds of
things where I listen to something I
read something I think know anything
they've heard their little viewpoint
they're a try they've heard their little
viewpoint don't can't engage with
anything outside of it and therefore
just turn on anyone who asks any kinds
of questions and so on and that is a new
I mean you could see that growing from I
think from the 50s on work but it's come
to the point yeah I think there's more
thinkers yeah this is what my friend
Peter Bogosian calls a secular religion
and that basically there that there's no
Redemption narrative that if you were if
you were born the wrong way in this case
cisgender and heterosexual white male
that you better bow forever because the
second you don't bow they have to kick
you out the original sin yeah you you
are I mean truly you're you're born with
original sin I thought we'd shipped to a
couple things that away from the college
campus for just a second and some things
that I know we have a little bit of
disagreement on so one of the big issues
right now is every week there's another
story about this monument being taken
down or many of you probably saw it at
George Washington's Church in Alexandria
Old Town Alexandria Virginia
it was the same church that robert e lee
went to so they wanted to take down the
robert e lee plaque which they did and
then they decided it wasn't fair just to
take his down because george washington
was also a slave owner so then they took
George Washington's down as well now
George Washington as I said he was a
slave owner he when he died half of his
his half of the slaves I think it was
about half were freed and Martha's half
did stay you can go to his house outside
of DC and they they do a wonderful very
forthright honest talk about it but it
brings me to the monument issue because
I'm a believer right now that none of
these monuments should be taken down i
to me these are they they are historical
events whether you like them or not it's
part of the fabric of what brought us
here and what i would do is put perhaps
a counter you can I
the counter monument or you could add a
plaque that explains a little bit more
about why you shouldn't be worshipping
at the altar of robert e lee not that i
think that that's really what people are
doing but that you would i would want to
educate more rather than remove things
there seems to be a huge movement on the
left unfortunately to remove things and
to me it's like all right if we allow
them to remove robert e lee well now now
they're taken down in george washington
and eventually they'll come for for my
favorite founder Thomas Jefferson
they're gonna come for his house at
Monticello where by the way they give an
incredible explanation of how he owned
slaves yet he was writing the laws that
were eventually going to free the slaves
so my feeling is that you can't give an
inch on this because they will never
stop but uncle I know I know you have a
slightly different take on that yeah I
mean I think both sides are wrong and it
it's you have to make that argument so
if I don't think I think many of these
statutes should be taken down but not
for the reasons that are being advanced
by so many of the activists and I do
think it is they view it as this is the
start so those first take down robert e
lee and then washington and then
jefferson and i think you have to make a
distinction between those the
confederacy I view as an abomination and
when most of these statues were put up
late 19th century in a movement and by
people trying to resurrect the prestige
of the Confederacy and I'm I'm from
Canada I found it very weird to come to
America in Virginia you go to Old Town
Alexandria and there's a statue to the
Confederacy these people are literally
traitors who killed Americans I view
them the same as the people who flew
planes into the building's in 9/11 is
that a little bit of a slippery slope
though because we're all just people of
our time so you know but the founders
that owned slaves again they were some
of them were writing the laws to
Friesland but that's we don't celebrate
Jefferson or Washington because they own
slaves but for the Confederacy you're
celebrating them because they defended
an institution of slavery and to me that
like that
if robert e lee had some kind of
distinction other than being lead her
the confederacy and that's what we were
celebrating that's one kind of thing but
we're celebrating him because he was the
leader and for robert e lee he had a
choice he was offered the Union Army and
turned it down and then took it sided
with the Confederacy right and do you
think in a modern sense though that a
lot of people are actually going there
to celebrate i know robert e lee's house
is there no i mean i think there's an
element but it's I would find it weird a
fight I'm half German if I went to
Germany and there's all kinds of statues
to the Nazis the when they when the wall
fell for communism they toppled all
these statues of Lenin it's on and I
they were right to do so I would put
these in a museum and I would teach the
history and teach that this was
celebrated we put up statues for these
people after the Civil War and so I
wouldn't like try to erase it from
history but nor do I think it should be
in the city I mean a public monument
celebrates and I think you can make a
distinction I agree with you for sure
that the people advocating to take these
down don't want to make this distinction
and they will want to take down all our
things to Jefferson and to Washington
zone but I think you have to say no I I
mean I'm drawing a distinction between
these two and I think the side that's
just defending the statues because these
other people or irrationally want to
take them down they're wrong and the
people who rationally want to take them
down they're wrong and there's a third
way yeah it's funny I mean we've
discussed this before I don't like
taking the position of I'm not gonna do
something because I don't like the
people I'm negotiating with that's a
pretty shitty place to be sort of and we
see this in politics all the time no one
will negotiate because they know the
guys on the other so you know or they
think the guys on the other side won't
play fair so then they stop playing fair
and that's what kind of gets us to the
gridlock that we're out right now do you
have a feeling on this one way or
another well listening to you gentlemen
speak right now I'm thinking maybe the
the middle line would be what you
mentioned before which is having a
plaque there explaining the history so
not removing it and putting it in a
museum and explaining it but leaving it
where it is and having some sort of
description that explains it so that way
you don't start down the slippery slope
because once you remove it put any music
they're gonna insist that you remove
everything and eventually and put it in
a museum so yeah do you think there's
another piece of this that goes to sort
of what progressivism has become so it
sounds good right you're for progress
everyone's for progress that inherently
sounds good I would argue that what
progress would be would be equality of
opportunity that we should have laws
that protect everyone equally regardless
of your race or skin color or any of
that stuff and that really is what we
have on the books now but I it seems to
me that what this goes to is that part
of what progressivism has become is that
there is a need to actually erase
history because they want to apply our
2018 values to history and I guess
that's another piece of why I'm so
concerned about this yeah I mean I think
they want to rewrite history but I think
it's it and I think this is part of what
you're responding to there anti-american
they don't like this country and so to
take down monuments this is why I won't
stop it again they want to take down all
their money they want to take anything
that they think is about celebrating
Americans oh we're evil country from
their perspective and from a lot of
these bits it's the the whole you are
asking about identity politics I think
when I was in college you could see this
coming in and there were two doctrines
multiculturalism and ethnicity but if
you just take multiculturalism in this
way because I think multiculturalism is
a Cold War for anti Americanism it's all
cultures are not equal and that you can
study other cultures and you can learn
from other cultures and so on but I mean
I'm half German half Indian there's all
kinds of things about both of the my
cultures that I think are really bad and
the idea that that's like I should be
thinking though that's where I draw my
inspiration to because these happen to
be my ancestry so that it's more
interesting what's true and what's good
and if it happens to be that an Indian
contributed to that or a German did okay
and if they didn't like Hitler its I'm
not interested in it and and but it was
pushed that you should
think of yourself based on your culture
and that they're all equal but that just
elevates the bad and denigrates to do it
you know it's interesting I'm wondering
how many of you guys saw this whole
thing about the documentary about a poo
the problem with a poo from The Simpsons
did you guys catch this just in the last
okay so I saw some hands so that
basically a documentarian made a movie
saying that the idea of up who in effect
was a racist idea that he was played by
a white actor Hank Azaria who's wondered
idly be greatest voiceover actor of all
time you know the character of a poo he
was they did a whole episode on
immigration that he showed Homer why
immigration is good he's a vegan they've
talked about you know they've shown a
lot about Indian culture and he got
married in an Indian wedding and plenty
of other things I would argue he's a
beloved character and probably the best
maybe the best comedy of all time
certainly the first ten years of it and
yet and and at the same time the Indian
community in America is hugely
successful by every way we measure
success socioeconomically educationally
of every which way and yet I saw all
these people online and I got into it
with a blue Czech guy who happened to be
Indian on Twitter really wanting to play
a victimhood and I thought what power
this thing has what and he said well you
know when I was a kid and I heard this
from several people and I was a kid you
know I I'd be bullied and they'd call me
up who that no one wants to be bullied
no one but the idea that that then
should throw away all the success that
as a community Indian Americans have had
is crazy I suspect you mostly at least
agree with me yes and it's it's the the
multiculturalism celebrates the cultures
that don't assimilate and assimilate
doesn't mean losing everything it means
this wasn't the melting pot in America
meant you take stuff from different
cultures you put it in the pot and you
keep the stuff that's good and you toss
out the stuff that's bad and the
cultures that do this are the ones that
are more successful they adopt to
American values or Western values they
don't lose everything about that culture
they keep what's good about it like
Indians for instance really
value education and they kept that
element it's partly why they're
successful and what multiculturalism
elevates is they're sellouts yeah
because they haven't kept all their
backward things and there are arranged
marriages in this country and that is if
that's what you're celebrating
you're just celebrating something that's
bad and saying it's as good as
everything else that's just Sarah's down
so this is sort of like when you hear
that oh well this is an odd analogy for
this week but you know Starbucks is
coming to Harlem and then you know I
know that's not a great analogy for this
week but use something like that they're
coming to Harlem and then al sharpton
I'll say see their gentrifying our
neighborhoods they're kicking us out
even though what ultimately happens and
they've done many studies on this where
Starbucks goes suddenly there is more
economic success and everything else but
to on cars point about multiculturalism
as someone that was born Muslim but you
can save yourself X Muslim now how are
you able to or not able to integrate any
sort of those things that went into the
melting pot for Indians and for every
every other minority that is here in
America yeah well I did exactly that but
it was a very slow process because I had
to do it myself
brick by brick just figure out like you
know rebuild myself and figure out what
what are my values you know what what
parts do I want to keep and what parts
do I want to throw out and a lot of the
parts that I wanted to throw out like
taking off my job was the one of the
first things I did before I denounced
the religion even I was just very glad
to be able to just wear what I wanted to
wear not what I was being forced to wear
and which seems like it would be a lefty
I'm pretty high up there right yeah
so and I got rid of that and so it's
just really weird now to see people that
progressive people from liberal thinkers
now celebrating a backwards misogynistic
you no modesty culture so yeah it comes
back to what you were saying about you
know multiculturalism taking all
cultures and viewing them all is equal
and basically not throwing anything out
because if you throw
something out that means you're a
sellout you know but there are a lot of
things that needs to be thrown out this
is this is human progress we're talking
about slavery we threw that out right
like that's a good thing throwing out
things so it should be viewed
progressives should be all about that
yeah so we're progressive right so it's
interesting
obviously we focus so far mostly on
problems that we see with the left but
let's let's try to give the right
something you know I when I do these
events with with a are I with the Iran
Institute people say oh you see Rubens
in it with those far-right maniacs
that's what they think you're a maniac I
know this guy's a real extremist over
here now obviously I focused more on the
left because I came from the left and
for a certain set of years I was really
trying to reform the left I think now to
be totally honest and I and I
consistently say this on my show I'm
doing this a little more on the outside
I don't think that that liberalism at
least in the classical sense has
anything to do with the modern left
where that puts me I'm not exactly sure
but let's talk about the right a little
bit and people say well you don't
criticize the right enough and to me is
there some element of the right that is
racist or that wants some sort of ethno
state or that the KKK is involved in or
the Richard Spencer's of the world or
any of that of course those things are
completely antithetical to American
values to freedom to our Constitution
all of those things but to me I don't
focus on them because those things have
no institutional power I don't think
anyone here is being taught by a white
supremacist is anyone here possibly
being yeah I mean it just doesn't happen
at the college level where we know
they're being indoctrinated with leftist
ideas at the college level we don't see
this even in politics I don't think that
Donald Trump is a white supremacist do
you think that's a fair take of what's
happening on the right that
acknowledging yeah there's something
wrong with the fringe of it but it
hasn't sort of
ensconced the whole thing yeah I mean I
don't
we've talked we were talking about this
I don't think of it exactly in terms of
the right but I do think so if you look
at the Trump and the Trump phenomenon it
has energized that what you're calling
the fringe it's given them more
confidence more power more of a platform
and that's a threat though I agree with
you it's much less but they're just
their numbers and and particularly as
you said the institutionalization of it
is much less but if you think of other
elements that are thought of as this
belongs with the Conservatives and the
right religion belongs there
and I think you can't understand
America's inability to deal with the
threat from Islamic totalitarianism and
just to be able to think about it
without understanding that America it's
been pushed and pushed and this comes
way more from the Conservatives that
religion is a force for the good and so
what does it mean that you've got people
flying planes into buildings in the name
of a religion it's it has to be they
hijacked it they perverted it they
corrupted it and yet if you look at the
history of religion this is not some
unusual act suicide bombing and this
kind of it's not if we when you look at
the wars between the Catholics and the
Protestants and the amount of killing
and the torture and so on it's not this
is all this is some weird thing that
we've never seen before but they're not
willing to go there and ask those
questions and really drive home could
this have something to do with religion
or not and I think that is coming way
more from the right all right well we're
sitting next to someone that doesn't
have a problem talking about that you
were doing a lot of nodding there we see
this get up you skated constantly that
it's about geopolitics or it's about
economics or it's about education I
think there might be some elements of
truth to any one of those and and we of
course we have to judge these people on
their individual motives and actions but
you were nodding to a lot of that and
you've lived through a lot of it so can
you yeah I was nodding through a lot of
that because I I do agree that that is a
criticism of people that are on the on
the right because they are generally
conservative religious people as well
and so I was an interview with God said
he was saying why look at all of the
hate and violence in the
why can't this be considered hate speech
and I said because then the Bible would
have to be to write and that and so
nobody wants to go there and so then
they talk about other things I say no
it's because of unemployment it's
because of Education it's because
they've hijacked their religion it's
because let's think of any other reason
other than acknowledging the truth which
is that there that the religion teaches
this this is you've got 1.6 billion
Muslims and the the one book that they
read tells them hundreds and hundreds of
times that the most valued person
amongst them would be the the person
that gives their life for a law the
person that gives their life in Jihad
the killing the non-believers that's
that's what this book teaches and so a
certain percentage of the people that
are hearing this it's gonna resonate
with them and they're gonna respond to
it and they're gonna do what they're
told now you know a humans are I think
innately good right none of us we don't
we're not going around murdering each
other so you would it would be you know
it's gonna be a small percentage of
course the people that would actually
act on this but any percentage of 1.6
billion is just bad odds right so is the
odd dichotomy there with religion and we
discussed this a little bit earlier but
we live in a Christian nation
I mean it's founded on judeo-christian
principles basically but but we live in
a predominantly Christian country here
we have an ex-muslim we have you you
weren't born into any religion but you
come from a half Indian half German
family into America I'm a gauge you I
mean I said you earlier thank God you
know it's being slightly procedures but
thank God we live in America because
this is the place that allows us to do
this what does that say actually about
perhaps a Reformation that Christianity
has had that maybe people like you were
trying to get Islam to do although I
know that's not really what your your
particular goal is but Christianity has
changed a lot right and I think we have
to acknowledge that yeah I don't think
America is a judeo-christian nation I
think of it as it's a nation of the
Enlightenment and I think it's wrong to
think of it as reforming religion though
I can understand why people describe it
like that I think what happened with
Christianity is it became marginalized
and defamed so you had from the
Renaissance onward
people taking much more seriously that
we have to think for ourself that we can
think for ourselves that we can reason
we can arrive at knowledge you at the
Scientific Revolution and then we need a
political system that enables us to do
that and then you get Locke and others
thinking about that and it culminates
with the United States of America which
is it's not accident the freedom of
speech is in the First Amendment it's
crucial crucial and it's an aspect of
freedom of thought and what happened
then with Christianity is they it either
would go away completely or sort of has
to make peace with science and peace
with now we've got the idea that people
should be free and and that's the way in
which it's sort of pushed to the side
it's marginalized and it's dfangs so
separation of church and state is you
can't wield political power you have for
centuries but religion can no longer
wield political power and that's the
sense of defanging it and that's what
has to happen in the Muslim world I
think so it has something positive has
to replace Islam and then it will be
pushed it won't go away completely but
are we pushed to the side and crucial is
that there has to be separation of state
and mosque
yeah you can't wield political power
religion cannot wield political so again
you're nodding a lot I mean I know
there's there's a split right now in the
Muslim world basically between X Muslims
and the Reformers yeah you're you're
sort of of the mind that this cannot be
reformed that this should be well I'm I
am an atheist so I'm going to you know
if somebody asks me what my opinion is
and I'll I'll go to what my truth is but
I don't I don't have any I support
people that are trying to reform their
religion I'm not a Muslim so I'm not
going to try and reform that religion
it's not my place to do that I'm not
interested
doing that but I'll support people who
are trying to do it because they're the
path that they want to get to is
secularism as humanism is the liberal
values that I hold dear so yeah all
linked hands with the Buddhist and a
Christian and a you know Hindu and
whoever doesn't matter Zoroastrian da
let's go but we we all agree on the same
goal so yeah it doesn't matter to me but
I think in the Muslim world what we have
it's an exact opposite of what the what
it is here so you were talking about
Christianity being defamed I mean yeah
sure there's a Bible Belt of people that
are super conservative and that maybe do
want religion in the public sphere but
there are a minority here but in the
Islamic world you flip that around it's
the majority of people who want to Simon
the public sphere who want it to be
filling who want 100 percent Islamic
societies they want to get rid of all
non-muslims and there are quite a few
countries that are already have
succeeded in that you know we were
speaking earlier about Egypt who you
know Egypt was successfully got rid of
almost all its Jewish people I think he
was like five women left or something
there was one Jewish man left and he had
to leave because obviously his you know
he was not safe and Christians are there
working on them right like now there's
like 10 percent of Christians there and
look around the whole area look at the
Christians in Iraq look at the
Christians in Somalia look at the
Christians and Syria anywhere you know
this is their being they want to get rid
of all other ideas and narratives and
thoughts you were talking about teaching
one book I mean that's a snap you read
this one book you do not read any other
books it's a waste of time you focus on
memorizing this book not just not
reading it and understanding it and and
debating it and having conversations no
memorizing it that's where the value is
is regurgitation so yeah I've noticed
just for that last point that that's the
Christian world was like before the Ren
or before the discovery of Greek
philosophy they used to preach and teach
in Latin then nobody understood yeah but
it was good enough because you're
indoctrinated you're not it's not about
understanding or knowledge it's about
indoctrination and that's what that
Christianity doesn't look like that
anymore
yeah our nearly as much but that's the
Enlightenment that did that
how much worse do you think this is all
gonna get as we're watching the rise of
parties in Western Europe that are
genuinely xenophobic that want to change
the nature of their countries just as
parties on the Left want to change it
and they've got all these immigration
problems always I'm a believer that this
can get better I'm an optimist by nature
but that it seems to me that in America
in Western Europe especially it's going
to get a lot worse before it gets better
do you think that's a fair estimation
yeah I think unfortunately you're right
I mean sometimes I read about things
that are happening in Europe or you know
we're in the UK and I think like I feel
like a civil war is brewing in some of
these countries people are really really
angry you know and I think it will have
to get worse before it gets better
something's time something's gonna have
to blow yeah it's interesting that this
is happening worldwide right I mean the
amount of email I get from other
countries where people are people in
Australia and Japan and Brazil are
talking about the exact same things that
we're talking about in Canada and
America yeah and the whole rise of Islam
in the last 75 years in the Middle East
I mean it's had repercussions worldwide
and then with the immigration it's a
problem in all kinds of places and part
of I think the reason we do these kinds
of events and what we're trying to do if
you only allow the Islamists and the
sort of the people who there is an
element of racism and bigotry if if you
only allow those two to talk about this
issue you're finished if we can't have
an honest conversation about it then
you're going to have dishonest
conversation it's good that this is a
conflict
yeah and it's either gonna be resolved
by people who are actually thinking and
trying to do the
right thing or it's gonna be resolved
and this is why it feels like a civil
war is coming because if the people who
could that it's not that every Muslim
should be tossed out or something but
there is a problem with Islamic
totalitarianism and a real
fundamentalism in the religion that
we've seen with other religions and we
have to address it and deal with it and
if rational people don't irrational
people are going to so are you hopeful
then for this alignment because look I
see what's happening with my show and
the things that I'm doing and the amount
of people that are coming for those
conversations and I go wow there's
there's actually something very cool
happening on the other hand if you just
look on Twitter all day long or are you
just following social media or Facebook
or whatever you only hear crazy people
screaming all day long or if you watch
CNN all day long it's hysteria or if you
watch MSNBC or Fox I would recommend not
watching none of them but that we're
sort of caught in these two things
hysteria but the real question is how
many of us maybe don't have all
certainly none of us have all the
answers but are at least willing to ask
questions I think it's way more than
[ __ ] then then we are led to believe
I don't think that these two groups are
on opposite sides of the spectrum I
think that though both those groups are
on the same side of the spectrum like
you were talking about liberal versus
liberal or authoritative person yeah so
I that's the thing that gets to me is
people talk about it like two opposite
things like if you speak out against
Islamism then that makes you a racist
you know what I mean
but even though if there was a political
party that was anti-woman and anti-gay
et cetera et cetera the left would love
that political party right I mean they
would they would hate them yes but in
this I really almost scream but it but
in this case yeah in this case all of
the things that they purport to love are
the things that they're aligned that's
so confusing yeah what do you make of
that brown skin it really is that simple
it really is that simple yeah they just
don't want to be racist so they can't
speak out against this ideology they
will speak out about Christianity till
the cows come home
Yeah right even though like you were
saying it's been defamed why are we
still talking about it like there's sure
there are aspects that need to be
criticized but it really is
hanging fruit it's the molehill and
they're ignoring the mountain right so
yeah I just just I think it's because
we've been trained that all cultures are
equal and you cannot speak about other
people because that means that you think
that you are somehow better and it makes
you a white supremacist so you have to
bite your tongue and not speak out
against bad ideas even FGM that's right
genital mutilation is okay too in Canada
in in the UK there's issues with our
actual our leaders that are that will
not so our leader in Canada Justin
Trudeau was saying you cannot call
female genital mutilation barbaric
really yeah he should say that to our
friend ayaan Hirsi Ali Jason sees so
what is barbaric if holding down a young
girl and cutting out her clitoris isn't
barbaric then when would we use that
word you know and you had the same thing
with with Corbin in the UK like they are
so afraid of being racist that they will
actually support horrible ideas as long
as it's a brown person that's holding
those ideas yeah
and it's part of the anti Americanism
and anti Western so I don't acts as I
said I don't think of America as a
judeo-christian country but many people
do including many people are the leaders
of the progressives who are actually
regressives and authoritarians they
think of it like that so they're happy
to attack Christianity and Judaism
because they see it as part of the
attack on America in the West and
they're happy to prop up Islam and
whitewash it because it helps tear down
the West and unfortunately again I agree
with completely what you said many of
the followers students who bought into
this this is all they've been taught so
a very different view but the leaders or
there's a very corrupt motivation there
I think yeah so we've been speaking for
maybe a half hour so maybe even more
than that I don't think we've said Trump
once which is I thought that would be
worthy of applause but we haven't said
Trump once but of course if we're
talking about free speech we should talk
about Trump
you know because I think that there's
there's an idea out there that that he
is the biggest threat to free speech now
for me personally I think the bigger
threat to free speech is ourselves I see
far I'm far more worried about
self-censorship at the moment than the
government telling you not to say
something actually I don't see the
government really coming for anybody do
I have all sorts of problems with his
tweets and all that stuff sure but even
if you look at what happened with Colin
Kaepernick and and Ealing for the anthem
well everyone was screaming as if this
was the end of American civilization and
ironically actually everything worked
the way it was supposed to the president
you may not like his opinion but he's
allowed to say what he thinks about a
player kneeling the player is allowed to
kneel or not kneel the owners of the
team are allowed to either bring these
players on or suspend them if they so
see it fit and the the audience you guys
are allowed to buy tickets or not buy
tickets and buy jerseys or not buy
jerseys like actually everything worked
no one was put in jail people were upset
people were angry that's exactly what is
supposed to happen but if you listen to
the narrative that the media was pushing
the entire time it was this idea that
somehow totalitarianism or some evil
force was actually at work and yet every
within the confines of free speech and
how freedom is supposed to work it all
worked why is that idea not taking root
we should all pat ourselves on the back
honestly we're very very lucky to be
living in a country where so much blood
has shed for this to work like we're I'm
very grateful I'm I lived on the other
side of the world like ion was saying
this to you to like she's seen the other
side of the coin so we're I see these
kinds of things and I feel just joy and
happiness and grateful but that this can
happen so is it partly a media thing
then that they just want to keep you
watching keep you clicking can I upset
here's I think we also disagree a bit I
don't think everything worked exactly
though I think it's true that in essence
there still respect in America for free
speech a lot of things worked here but
there's something very problematic and
very dangerous I think in you say a
president can have opinions I think yeah
but when the government has so much
control over industry it's is he
expressing an opinion or is it a veiled
threat towards the NFL if you don't tow
the lines and if for Trump but he's not
this it's not unique in this regard
Clinton did this too it was very scary I
thought could trump with Amazon and with
the Washington Post and with some of the
stories about antitrust and mergers that
he doesn't like to come so he's gonna
we're gonna make it hard for you to
merge and so that's you can say
expressing an opinion about Amazon but
there's threats there as well and I
think it's very dangerous but Hillary
Clinton did with this with Exxon and so
on about well you can't talk like this
about climate change and go cuz I don't
like what you say was the she didn't say
that yeah but that's the threat and and
it's a dangerous thing yeah and I
completely hear you on that and I'm
certainly gonna be the last one to sit
up here and defend big government yeah
but I think just in the in the read but
the part that we can look at yes our
lens right now everything worked is it a
threat is Trump behind the scenes were
they talking to the NFL people about
losing some of their tax benefits and
some other things and that they
potentially gonna lose them
perhaps and then then you're using
government coercion to affect it that
would be different but I think in this
case it basically all worked it's funny
because when you talk about this I
really can sense your sort of exhaustion
with like just people that don't accept
the goodness here yeah because I I feel
like I'm really I feel like I worked so
hard to pull myself out of the darkness
and to pull my daughter out of the
darkness and to come out into the light
and so to see people that were born and
raised in the light who didn't luckily
didn't have to experience the darkness
are actually kind of fetishizing it you
know that's that's where they want to go
but they're not I really think that they
just don't understand what they're doing
you know I think that a lot of people on
the left really do come it's coming from
a good place
they do not want to be racist and they
do not want to be homophobic and sexist
and all that other stuff so they're
overcompensating but they're not
realizing that through this
overcompensating they're actually
becoming totalitarian in their in what
they're doing do you know what I mean
yeah so I hate to ask this question but
I'll reference saying that you said a
little while ago I mean you say you said
the phrase civil war I get this question
a lot now I'm seeing this a lot in my
email inbox like is are we at this thing
where now we have you know two forces
working at each other that one has to
win but we don't win in the battle of
ideas anymore we may have to battle it
out in some other way out I would be
completely against it I think there
would be no it would be it would be the
ending of the American experiment I
think in effect but do you see that as a
truly possible outcome of this I see it
down the road it's a possibility this
kind of breakup you've seen it in the
past in Europe you've seen it people
didn't expect that World War 1 could
happen and if you read some of the just
the popular newspapers magazines of pre
World War one it was well it's gonna be
progress forever and the idea that you
could have World War one which was this
senseless war of enormous death and
destruction and then you get World War
two partly a result of it like that that
people if you said in the late 19th
century you're gonna in the next 50
years have two world wars where
everybody's that keep trying to kill
each other they were thought you're
crazy and yet it happened so you it
there's a possibility I don't think it's
I wouldn't bet on it still that's what
but nor should one think no that's
impossible think that could happen yeah
well I think I think you guys know that
my answer to this is of course and and I
know that you guys agree with this is
that the only way we can solve these
problems is by judging each other as
individuals and that's it that
that is literally the antidote to
prejudice to racism to all of all of
these ideas that have just taken root
right now that are so incredibly
incredibly dangerous I said